um give me your top five rappers
ever
Pac uh Bone Thugs is a group
forzy for Crazy Bone right now
um definitely
um [__] this is tough I'm biased man I'm
[__] I'm old school dog I'm I mean
Snoop you got Pock bone Snoop
um I mean Biggie's in there for
sure
and [__] dude this tough I'm so old
school man I'm so old school when it
comes to music
uh [__] I'm going get ridiculed for this
list
um fifth person bro DMX [__] it DMX and
you got to work with DMX yeah before he
pass which is crazy I I related to this
[__] a lot now there's a bunch of people
I should have said politically or
whatever but that's just what comes to
my head right now what I'm listening to
right now I'm surprised you didn't do
the political Bay Area rapper to throw
in there well that's his own list you
know that's his own list what's the Bay
Area list
[__] um you know the
Jacka um The
Jacka M Dre for
E40 San
Quinn and I mean bro you got to give two
shortest price you got give two short
yeah yeah it's crazy I I feel like
people who aren't from the Bay will
never quite uh understand MC Dre or san
Quinn San Quin or san Quinn or even The
Jacka for sure The Jacka that's my
number one Bay Area you know I'm one of
his biggest fans but the San Quinn is
probably one of the best rappers at this
at the bay I think out the West Coast he
just never got a chance shine like that
on a very very major level but like
Quinn still got heat to this day yeah
yeah for sure now I think it's crazy cuz
like I had I had that talk with
um uh somebody else from the bay that I
won't mention but we we're kind of
talking about how like like
I understand why M Dre is important I
understand you know I I also understand
from what a lot of people told me that
people didn't really in terms of the
streets [__] with him and like like at
least the his thiz era [__] until he
passed it was more like some Berkeley
[__] and then once he passed people kind
of really truly appreciated gravitated
to him yeah he did you know what I'm
saying um all right man well [__] hey
before we go can you give me the last
time we hung out you gave me
um
OG uh burner in the in the
uh I forget what happened you almost you
afraid you were going to get robbed in
the mountains of Humble County yeah that
[__] went super viral let's let's dive
back 15 years 20 years burn give me the
another random just Story Time with
Burner give me a crazy story about a
situation that might have been dicey
back in the
day um it could have been in Humble
County it could have been in the Streets
of San Francisco give me give me a
little anecdotal little tidbit man
before we go
well I guess a good one would be
um I let someone handle something for me
one time and uh you know I just I felt
him my gut that it wouldn't be the right
move but I said bro like be very
attentive these guys are kind of like
these guys are kind of Shifty and I
don't think they're going to rob you by
gunpoint but I feel like something's
going to go wrong with it you know I'm
going to let you handle this cuz I'm not
around but like be very attentive to
what happens he's like for sure I got
you so he goes to meet up with this guy
in the hotel and he gives him the bags
and a duffel bag and the guy gives him
the money the moneyyy is vacuum sealed
and uh you know it looks right hundreds
on top whatever and there was two vacuum
seal bags and kind of made a joke like
what you don't trust me want to count
here you really want to count it all
here I got [__] to do I got to move I
got to go box these up and get them out
of here D was like yeah you know he's
like bro at least bust open one you can
count it real quick and and the dude
opened up for him the vacuum seal bag
and hand him a stack and counted through
a whole stack it's all H is boom boom
boom cool put it back in he's like bro I
got to go I got to move you know what I
mean boom my boy takes off gets to where
he's going opens up the vacuum seals and
the rest of all the stacks are just 100
on top of all ones o and I'm like he
calls me and tells me like bro you
really let this man pull out the stack
and cter for you like I mean he didn't
count for him but you really let him
open that pack up and give you he knew
was probably you let him give you the
right corner stack you didn't go through
anything else he's like bro he was
moving so fast it was nervous it was
just seem Shady he was opening up the
packs and start smelling the room I just
want to get out of there with all that
bread and I was worried about getting
robbed when I left I'm like but you
worried about getting robbed when you
left but you got robbed right there he's
calling the D's phones for D's phones
out serviceing [__] how much how much
money are we talking I don't even
remember at the time it was like
probably like 16 years ago or something
like that but I just know my boy got
[__] big time and it fell on him I'm
like bro you were there to handle it you
were there to count the bread I told you
what to do he didn't do it so that's on
you you got to eat that [__] L yeah
he never paying me back for it but yeah
that was a random one so and for all
them bad boys out there if someone comes
with a neatly stack of hundreds all
flattened out perfect in the vacuum seal
go through it yeah you should never just
take the vacuum seal of money just open
it up make sure it's there it's out I
mean you're already you're already
somewhere doing a deal it's I mean
you're already invested in this
situation counted out so you know that's
just a good old story that happened
someone pulled a slick one on my little
homie and my little homie is supposed to
pay me back but he did not the crazy
[__] is like right now in Downtown
LA it's it's it's the Wild Wild West
like if you're downtown and you live in
a highrise I guarantee you there is a
Trapper on your floor and if you see
guys moving around with tons of luggage
all the time they're not
traveling La is wild right now yeah
rappers stop shouting out these these
trap guys man let them like let them
build an organic following that [__] is
crazy [__] snitching dude dog it's
like yeah it's it's crazy man um well
look man obviously uh people can go I
mean you got when's the New Mexico
opening how uh November 3rd so November
3rd that's coming new music coming
collab project with be real on the way
Mazy uh OG Jeezy there you cookies
clothing is going crazier than ever yeah
I feel like you guys probably I mean
keeping Zoomies alive at this point
Zoomies has been a great part [__] man
you guys are [__] front and center
yeah they they've been a great partner
we got two uh shoes coming out next year
with somebody I'm not going to say who
tennis shoes yeah like sneakers are they
fly
yeah hm
okay I keep coming that you know I keep
coming with it man you know going be a
cookie sneaker coming yeah they try to
write me out man it's not happening
cookies I love the slides yeah slides
are good but I'm talking about like a
partnership with a bigger company like a
a collab sneaker a collab sneaker yeah
yeah it's not just us putting it out no
it's a collab with a pretty big brand m
relevant brand has why' you guys stop
doing denim or is it you guys not doing
as much cuz you're a big genan guy yeah
I mean I don't know that's just just
tough focus on T business yeah yeah
focus on what works man well look uh
cookie shoes on the way so much going on
um oh real quick uh I know you're a big
Maui guy mhm I had to be tough to see
what happen in Maui cuz that's when I go
to Maui I stay like that's where I'm at
I'm always in in l eating food and you
know I go to that big ass tree and eat
do like it's so sad it's a it's a
terrible situation shout out to everyone
on the ground putting in that work out
there in Maui a lot of people are making
sure that they're taken care of I know
that's kind of like your like dream like
if I retire like you always talk about
like going to Maui yeah I mean I
definitely want to be in in Maui or
Kawaii but like yeah shout out to
everyone in Maui I've I've checked in
I've helped out you know I'm not going
I'm not one of those guys that publicly
just post what I do for things but you
know I've helped out in the ways I can
and I know that there's good people on
the ground making sure people are good
out there for sure man well there it is
Big Burn I appreciate you brother
appreciate you bro yes sir yes sir boom